wow this is what I mean guys
what's the what's the housing corruption
will you tell me about it
what is it we got something for 25 years
okay we always have been in two bedrooms
for over 25 years
[Music]
I'm confused are you guys like are you
married families
okay and then the housing that the
children have I'm just trying to
understand
one bedroom okay
okay
what are you looking to change we're
looking to change the whole house in
corruption the whole housing system is
correct so what are you doing
housing
so everybody right right what is right
right give everybody
a problem
so I'm just curious okay I'm curious I I
live over there so like I look down
there what's that I don't understand I'm
not from here okay okay okay okay
I'm trying to I'm trying to understand
what's going on I see these protests
that I never know on what we're doing
so my question is what do you want
change like you want more houses we want
to know why are we asking them to sit
down with us to talk to us
so you work here you don't have to be
working
um
well I I know but I'm just trying to
figure out what you guys trying to
change so I'm trying to tell you okay
okay we are overcrowded today and I
wanted to know why am I also started
let's say he's saying to us that Baro is
overcrowded okay
okay so what's stopping you from like
going out of the city where it's less
crowded let me tell you what stop it
okay
and
you
might go to another Power can I claim
and say that my power is good can you
have me a place okay can I say that in
public because the fun they're taking
says they are manageable to get houses
for those people because people like so
they're supposed to get houses for
people that's what they meant so they're
supposed to get people houses
and then so what it like are they are
you guys like you were born here from
London no not all of us
[Music]
[Applause]
we've got the right to get Social houses
affordable houses wherever available in
this battle okay I shouldn't have
stopped over again and take my kids from
the barrel for them for them having a
houses but choosing who to give to okay
does that make sense so what I'm trying
to get is if the norm of residents
cannot get our social houses or even
avoidable houses why are there higher
people are getting it why are the higher
people so here's how I I think and I
don't really understand it so this is
outside looking at I would think like
why would I why wouldn't I just like go
get moved somewhere else I'll tell you
what
why would I move from someone else why I
have arrived from my own power does that
make sense why can I not let's say okay
let's say you're working in a job today
your job yeah it's easier for you to say
I need to leave the job for me to get my
mental health yeah
okay okay you are allowing with the
behavior those abuser to get abused more
no I don't think so yeah because I think
I think they're kind of soft today I
think we're kind of like like if I
you're gonna say a boss is abusive dog
we have great lives yes
I'm sorry there's another person okay
let's say why would I allow abuser to
abuse me while I can fight back and
change the society so like the way I
think is like who are you to change
society individual changes Society
but they're all Society to change it so
again I don't know the system here but
to me this sounds like narcissism like
you know what is your opinion yeah yeah
the way I'm saying my own opinion my
opinion yes if I want to be able to move
it's easy for me to move but why would I
why would I move and allow the abuser to
live in my own place yes why do I need
to stop
who's abusive and what is it what is it
what is abuse what do you mean like what
is abuse
when I hear the word abuse I don't think
it means anything anymore because they
call everything
so they call like um if I there's like
emotional abuse now I'm like that
doesn't count yeah I think abuses we
shouldn't be focusing on everything yeah
it is our rights I don't have to change
my whole life because assistant want me
to change it yeah if I wanted to move
from the apartment because I want to
move not because the system force it to
me does that make sense yeah but like to
me it's like it wasn't in all choices
but why do you have a Farrow mind why do
we have a prime minister
[Applause]
I'm American we got a president
are we as a commander-in-chief he's got
to pick us to go to war or not yeah yeah
yeah so again she's making a decision
yes he does that's correct it's the same
that's the same thing but they're making
a decision on behalf
[Laughter]
what do you think
why why because it's not available
[Music]
if it tells you tomorrow to get out of
the flight you have to get out do you
know that well I would be very upset let
me tell you let me ask you another
question okay okay if you tell him to
fix the kitchen today your kitchen broke
down and it has the Orlando Police can
you fix my kitchen what are they gonna
say to you they come within like a day
it's a great place no they cannot you
think it is
who your landlord is okay guess what
they said the landlord they want the
money they want you to pay them okay but
at the same time they're not gonna fix
anything and that is to what I'm trying
to tell you right now okay the higher
people are getting paid for your money
okay okay
now we're asking for free houses
what we're asking is I work I will okay
I should be able to go to my door and
then get paid for that okay
you shouldn't you're not gonna tell me
go to a landlord and then that landlord
today tomorrow gonna decide
I can't decide we might be on the same
side I don't know I thought you
me out
that makes sense
okay does that make sense okay here's
what I think with the housing you could
tell me if we agree with this okay I
think the landlord if you don't pay he
should be able to kick you out no not
easy if you don't pay let's say if you
wanted that house you decided to win it
forgot about the pain I think you if if
your lease is up you gotta go yeah and
if you decide I want to move into that
flat I'm still out even though I was
paying him every month yes does that
make sense no it does to me so where's
the stability right so if you have a
year release I don't think he should be
able to kick you out at any time but if
the lease ends yeah you got to go that's
why I'm telling you yeah we need to use
the stability okay our power that we
work at and their policies and
guidelines by the way you may be
American but let me tell you about
United Kingdom okay it's their policies
on guidelines it is their rules okay who
created that all this conflict okay and
then you want us to live on it does that
make sense we are only using the system
the system they provide I'm using they
again that the systems
our rights does that make sense no if I
came to America today I wouldn't have
been right because I'm not married does
that make sense yes but I am the United
Kingdom unfortunately okay and I can't
use that system okay does that mean so
your job shouldn't be
for me to have a British basketball but
then I can't act in any equal act but if
the system is set an equal act does that
make sense they cannot tell me United
Kingdom are Multicultural today but
again there's a racism inside of it you
either you either racist or you're not
okay and I can respect both okay do you
know what I mean so you cannot send
you're saying they're racist yeah I am
saying they are racist of course they
are racist everyone knows United Kingdom
Heart races undeticated yeah
there's a direct racism
let me talk
yes
or maybe you should work I'm not going
to agree with like this
foreign
[Music]
wow I think he's on some sort of drugs
wow
well guys I didn't really understand
that but you know I kind of liked him at
the end until they started talking about
all the oh this crack has yelling at me
oh man
they they were with me on the women
student vote but uh
I don't know what the housing stuff I
don't really understand it there's
protests all the time where I live like
I just see them out there protesting and
I kind of just thought it was going to
be women whining I mean they're whining
a bit but
I mean they're whining a bit nicer I
don't know
um so
yeah let me know what you guys think
maybe the comments can explain what the
hell they were talking about
um
anyways like the video guys goodbye